an accusation that shook westminster a
three-day hunt for a tory mp seen
watching pornography in the commons
chamber it ended hundreds of miles away
in devon with an apology but few answers
can you understand the upset that you
might have caused of course i said yeah
i apologize for that but i was still the
way to find this of being played
you maintained this was
something that was sent to you it was
not something that you had searched i
will await the
awakening inquiry
the only reason we say that is because
we think it happened twice is that right
we will wait the finals year
i'm sorry but how do you not know how
many times it happened when you were
involved
i will await the findings of the inquiry
that gentleman i think is probably
enough
a member of parliament for 12 years neil
parish has now had the conservative whip
suspended he says he'll stand down as an
mp if found guilty by the common
standards commissioner his wife
described the allegations as
embarrassing but is standing by her
husband
she said people shouldn't be looking at
pornography he would never just sit
there with people looking she went on if
you were mad with every man who looked
at pornography you would not have many
wives in the world
the case has reignited a debate about
westminster's culture all of us uh as uh
women in parliament have uh been
subjected to uh inappropriate language
uh to you know wandering hands there are
a few for whom uh you know too much
drink or indeed a sort of you know a
view that somehow being elected makes
them you know god's gift to women that
they can suddenly uh please themselves
that is never okay fundamentally if
you're a bloke keep your hands in your
pockets
labour trying to suggest the tories have
a particular problem the conservatives
have obviously known for days who this
mp was now having known they should have
done something about it they should have
acted swifter because it looks awfully
like a cover-up unfortunately they have
form on this from the owen patterson
scandal to failing to act against their
convicted pedophile mp imran ahmed khan
the mp until yesterday for wakefield
this is a government that's rotting from
the head down this is one of those
political stories it seems that
everybody has noticed everybody is
talking about
we're six days away from local elections
all over the country yet it seems so
hard to move on from the subject of
misdemeanors by mps
politics tarnished again by the sense
men in westminster have failed to behave
appropriately
soundcoat sky news